bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver au
Parlement européen à Bruxelles pour une
nouvelle émission d'Europe Hebdo et dans
cette émission nous irons en Espagne et
en Grèce en Algérie mais aussi en
Slovaquie grand reportage fraude fiscale
c'est Emilia qui plombe l'Europe et
direction Bratislava vous allez
découvrir comment la Slovaquie lutte
contre l'évasion fiscale sur la TVA pour
encourager les commerçants à éviter
l'argent noir et les consommateurs à
réclamé un ticket de caisse le
gouvernement organise une loterie avec
ces mêmes tickets mais avons un tout
autre sujet le dernier sommet européen
devait poser le problème de
l'immigration clandestine la question
est restée sans réponse reportée à juin
2014 pour mieux comprendre les enjeux je
vous propose d'aller à Melilla une
forteresse espagnole contre
l'immigration Mélina c'est un peu une
exception géographique c'est une ville
autonome espagnole qui se situe au
Maghreb une ville entourée de clôture
qui se protège jour et nuit contre tout
incursion reportage
le grillage fait 7 mètres de haut et il
y en a trois des comme ça ce rideau de
fer court tout le long de la frontière
qui sépare d'un côté le Maroc et de
l'autre côté l'Espagne alors bien sûr il
est surveillé jour et nuit par une
soixantaine d'agents de la garde civile
espagnole
le travail de la gare de civile dans ce
périmètre c'est de regarder tout le
temps de l'autre côté du grillage et
d'essayer de localiser les groupes de
subsahariens qui peuvent avoir
l'intention de s'approcher
48 caméras repèrent tout mouvement
suspect le centre de contrôle est en
contact permanent avec les gardes
civiles en patrouille
entre le moment où ce produit une alerte
sur le grillage que ce soit une alerte
produite par un coût une coupure que
nous avons que voir avec les caméras de
vision nocturne où les jumelles et
l'arrivée de la patrouille sur les lieux
il se passe une minute et demi à deux
minutes approximativement
3000 tentatives de passage ont eu lieu
depuis le début de l'année la plupart
ont été repoussés par les gardes civiles
et vous allez le voir tous les moyens
sont utilisés ici la gare de civile a
des doutes sur le pare-choc d'une 309
noire et pour cause à l'intérieur se
trouve un clandestin l'homme est inanimé
les douaniers vont mettre plusieurs
minutes à le désincarcérer il est vivant
il a payé au passeur la somme de 3000
euros pour entrer clandestinement en
Europe pour lui c'est raté
alors nous avons été rejoint sur ce
plateau par Malika benarabatou bonjour
vous êtes au député des Verts membres de
la commission culture et éducation
membre de la délégation pour les
relations avec le Maghreb vous venez de
regarder ce reportage donc des
clandestins qui se cachent dans des
pare-chocs pour pouvoir passer dans
l'eldorado européen ça vous aspire quoi
mais ça m'inspire de la colère parce que
c'est incroyable en 2013 nous en sommes
encore c'est une vision uniquement
vision sécuritaire et on a cette vision
où il y aurait comme ça des afflux de
migrants du Sud qui viennent c'est
terrible en 2009 déjà
on peut pas on peut pas laisser tout
ouvrir c'est pas laisser tout vert ça
c'est impossible on peut pas tout fermer
c'est c'est inhumain qu'est-ce que
l'Europe peut faire mais la question
c'est justement il faut avoir en tête
que c'est cette politique sécuritaire
qui produit de l'immigration clandestine
la seule vision qu'on peut avoir si on
veut être en cohérence avec nos valeurs
l'Europe est vue comme une comme des
pays qui ont une valeur humaine très
fort etc or avec cette façon cette
approche c'est que uniquement
sécuritaire nous sommes en incohérence
avec Madame nous ne sommes plus en
cohérence avec vos valeurs notre
fraternité d'égalité de liberté la seule
position qu'on peut avoir c'est la
circulation des personnes comment est-il
possible qu'on accepte la circulation
des marchandises qu'elle puisse circuler
et les humains ne pourraient pas
circuler ne pourraient pas être mobile
il faut quand même avoir en tête qu'il y
a un sentiment de mépris de tous les
jeunes du Sud eux ils sont au sud ils
ont l'impression qu'ils sont enfermés et
qui ne peuvent pas bouger tous les
jeunes du monde sont pareils ils ont
envie de voir le monde de découvrir etc
et le paradoxe c'est quand vous leur
permettre la mobilité au sein de l'Union
éenne je vous propose d'écouter deux de
haragas comme on les appelle en Algérie
deux clandestins qui ont tenté de gagner
les côtes espagnols depuis les plages
algériennes ça n'a pas marché sont au
micro de la chaîne de télévision
algérienne on écoute et vous réagissez
juste après
n'est pas une destination facile c'est
risqué
99% c'est la mort moi j'y suis allé et
notre embarcation s'est renversé près
des côtes toute la barque s'y retournée
et on s'est mis à nager
700 700 on envoie deux des nôtres nous
ramener avec cela à la barque et le
moteur
se trouve une plage discrète et on tente
notre chance
alors Malika ben rabat tour on les a
entendus qu'est-ce qui explique que
c'est cette jeunesse veuille partir
parce que c'est ça
leur papier
elle est vraiment des deux côtés nous
avons des pays du Sud qui ne sont pas en
capacité de pouvoir proposer une vie
descente envisageable pour les pour
leurs jeunesse je viens d'Algérie ou
nous avons une délégation la semaine
dernière et un pays comme l'Algérie qui
est un pays riche avec son pétrole et
son gaz n'a pas mis en place une
politique suffisamment démocratique la
seule façon c'est un pays qui n'arrive
pas à retenir sa jeunesse mais
proposer à permettre aux jeunes de se
projeter dans leur pays de manière
décente pour moi ce qui pourrait
permettre de sortir de cette folie et de
cette inhumanité ça serait une dynamique
avec une intégration de du Maghreb et
les peuples veulent cette intégration
permettrait de créer une dynamique
autour de comment on va ouvrir les
frontières déjà puisqu'il faut voir que
entre l'Algérie et le Maroc les
frontières sont fermées les frontières
terrestres dans le temps donc une
dynamique au niveau du Maghreb qui
permettrait de trouver de permettre aux
jeunes d'avoir des emplois il y a un
taux de chômage énorme
et en même temps la possibilité de lire
décemment il faut savoir que par exemple
les militants des droits de l'homme sont
harcelés en Algérie quotidiennement donc
il faut une ouverture aussi des espaces
publics des libertés publiques et en
même temps un projet qui permet de
mettre en marche et puis je vous le
disais au nord sortir d'une liaison
migratoire nous ne sommes pas dans un
moment de migration c'est ça qui ne va
plus nous sommes dans un monde où la
circulation et vraiment ce qui se passe
sur les droits de l'homme vous avez été
alerté par des par des organisations sur
la présence de centaines d'Algériens
dans des centres de détention en
Bulgarie des Algériens des Tunisiens des
Marocains des des d'autres Africains
racontez-nous bah alors moi j'étais
alerte
des conditions déplorables il y a même
les jeunes ont mis le feu pour essayer
de sortir les centres de rétention sont
à la fois dans les pays du Sud parce
qu'il y en a aussi en Italie et dans les
pays du Nord et nous sommes en train de
créer vous allez y aller qu'est-ce qui
se passe qu'est-ce qui se passe dans ces
centres de
la situation est d'une extrême pauvreté
il les jeunes se retrouvent tous
ensemble dans des conditions sanitaires
déplorables au tel point qui sont prêts
même à mettre le feu pour essayer de
trouver une solution
vous allez y aller oui je pense y aller
pour aller rencontrer ces jeunes mais je
pense que vraiment je suis très déçu
nous avons eu un conseil qui vient de se
tenir qui avait pour manger 2014 on est
toujours dans une approche avec des
visions à court terme les élections dans
quelques mois alors on va essayer de
gagner les élections ça peut pas marcher
et puis je voudrais quand même dire que
je suis très fâché en particulier en
France parce que je parle de la France
nous sommes dans une situation où les
les comment dire les politiques les
stratégies l'idéologie de l'extrême
droite est en train de gangrener toute
la société il y a une xénophobie des
élections européennes
droites
en tout cas merci Malika à tout d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et maintenant
place au reportage la fraude fiscale la
fraude à la TVA selon une étude
commandée par la Commission européenne
le manque à gagner pour l'Europe sur les
recettes de TVA c'est les vrais à 192
milliards d'euros en raison de la fraude
des impayés ou des erreurs vous allez
découvrir comment la slova quie lutte
contre l'évasion fiscale c'est un sujet
de Jérémy Hartman
en Slovaquie ce simple ticket de caisse
peut vous faire gagner une voiture ou
10000 euros la première gagnante de
cette loterie d'un nouveau genre habite
dans un village de l'Est du pays la
télévision nationale en a même fait ses
gros titres je ne voulais pas le
croire de bonheur la jeune famille
achetait des produits alimentaires dans
un petit magasin d'alimentation dans le
quartier de chaza pour 6 euros dépensés
ils en ont obtenu bien plus chaque fois
que je vais au magasin je mets de côté
l'étiquette
combien on a des voix enregistré
en 60 tickets
une loterie de ticket de caisse en
réalité une loterie contre la fraude
fiscale l'idée est originale elle a été
imaginée par le ministère des
financeslovaques pour lutter contre le
commerce noir selon la Direction des
Impôts la fraude à la TVA représenterait
une perte de 150 millions d'euros pour
les caisses de l'État un luxe que la
Slovaquie ne peut plus se payer en cette
période de crise
la perception des impôts c'est un
problème de longue date en Slovaquie
c'est d'ailleurs devenu la priorité de
notre gouvernement en 2013 nous avons
déclaré la guerre au fût fiscal
notamment à celle de la TVA
car à en croire le ministère des
Finances les commerces slovaquent la
fâcheuse tendance à ne pas donner de
ticket de caisse à leur client ou pire
produire de faux tickets le porte-parole
du ministère souhaite nous en montrer un
même lui s'est laissé berner
on voit bien la différence entre ces
deux tickets sur celui de gauche il n'y
a pas le sigle MF du ministère des
Finances ces initiales doivent être
inscrites sur chaque ticket légal avec
le code fiscal de la caisse qui a
enregistré l'achat
ici vous avez devant les yeux un ticket
provisoire qui ne rentre pas dans la
comptabilité du commerçant et donc ils
ne paye pas la TVA
pour en finir avec cette pratique l'idée
du ministère est simple chaque ticket de
caisse complète donne droit à une
participation gratuite à cette nouvelle
loterie avec à la clé jusqu'à 10000
euros de gains et plusieurs voitures à
gagner toute personne majeure peut
participer il suffit juste d'enregistrer
ses tickets
vous avez déjà joué à cette loterie non
pour le moment je n'en ai pas eu
l'occasion oui j'en ai entendu parler
mais ça ne m'intéresse pas trop oui j'ai
déjà joué deux fois ce sera la troisième
les participants doivent inscrire leur
ticket auprès de la Société nationale de
loterie la typo c'est elle qui a été
chargée de concevoir le dispositif
technique la plupart des joueurs passent
par le site internet mise à leur
disposition
il y a 4 éléments à saisir le décaper
c'est le numéro fiscal de caisse
enregistreuse la date l'heure et le
montant de la Charte ensuite il faut
rentrer un code de sécurité on clique et
c'est enregistré et pour les rares
joueurs qui n'utilisent pas internet il
est aussi possible de remplir sa grille
de loterie dans l'un des 2500 guichets
de la typo
là on a joué City aujourd'hui en tout
depuis deux semaines on en est à 25
lancement un slovaque sur 10 a déjà
participé à cette loterie un bon début
mais pas encore de quoi changer le
comportement des consommateurs à en
croire cette commerçante
pour le moment personne ne demande de
ticket
efficace ou pas la participation dépasse
en tout cas les espérances du ministère
des Finances surtout les Slovaques
sembla apprécier le concept de ce
nouveau jeu de hasard et pas seulement
parce qu'il est gratuit à consistait je
suis persuadé que c'est un bon système
les gens commencent à être conscients ce
qu'ils achètent ils vérifient les
tickets il gère mieux leur compte
avec ce jeu le gouvernement slovaque
souhaitait les consciences éduquer les
citoyens à consommer honnêtement en
réalité l'État ne touche aucune recette
directe avec cette loterie mais compte
bien à terme récupérer la TVA des
commerces en fraudeurs pour mieux les
repérer le ministère des Finances a
ouvert une adresse mail où les
consommateurs peuvent envoyer leur
réclamation et des renseignements
précieux pour l'administration fiscale
regardez voilà un mail qui vient
d'arriver à l'instant
il manque le numéro fiscal sur ces
tickets ils ont été scannés envoyés par
un certain Martin au lit un citoyen
lambda nous avons déjà reçu 2000 mails
pour des problèmes de non-conformité
nous avons contrôlé 700 commerces et
nous avons trouvé des irrégularités dans
la moitié des cornes
chaque citoyen se transforme le temps
d'un achat en inspecteur des impôts et
si pour l'instant les rentrées fiscales
ne sont pas encore significatives dans
quelques mois c'est peut-être bien
l'état slovaque qui pourrait toucher le
gros lot
voilà c'était un reportage de Jérémy
Hartmann le pillage des Etats les
voleurs de l'Union autrement dit la
fraude fiscale les particuliers les
entreprises qui soustraient l'argent aux
impôts les paradis fiscaux qui les
accueillent les spécialistes qui les
conseillent pour optimiser c'est le
débat d'aujourd'hui deux invités nos ont
rejoints bonjour vous êtes député
européenne allemand des membres de la
Cedeo le parti d'Angela Merkel on va
voir avec vous la vision allemande de
dans la lutte contre la fraude fiscale à
vos côtés limonoc bonjour vous êtes
débuté européen français socialiste et
économiste vous avez publié un essai que
Gérard Depardieu n'a pas dû lire il est
intitulé vive l'impôt alors vous venez
de regarder ce reportage alors cette
idée de gouvernement slovaque qui pour
lutter contre la fraude fiscale utilise
une loterie avec des tickets de caisse
ça vous inspire quoi c'est intéressant
parce que la TVA en France c'est plus de
50% des recettes fiscales et quand vous
allez voir un café au comptoir il y a
jamais de et pourtant vous payez plein
de pots TVA compris donc vous voyez ce
que je veux dire quoi un commentaire
une méthode de très drôle mais ça suffit
pas qu'est-ce qui arrive avec le
commerçant qui paye pas les impôts s'il
y a pas un système judiciaire derrière
ça sert pas à grand chose alors on l'a
bien compris la collecte des impôts
c'est de la compétence des États on fait
comment au niveau européen pour lutter
contre contre la fraude fiscale il y a
pas d'harmonisation fiscale en Europe au
Parlement européen nous avons voté
ensemble un rapport d'initiative qui est
le rapport de la députée cléva qui est
une véritable boîte à outils permettant
de lutter contre
l'évasion l'évitement et la fraude
fiscale en même temps qui représente
aujourd'hui en Europe quelque chose
comme mille milliards d'euros en France
la fraude et l'évasion fiscale c'est 80
milliards d'euros 80 milliards c'est
l'équivalent de notre déficit budgétaire
là aussi vous voyez ce que je veux dire
donc il est important de
remplir le consentement à l'impôt parce
que l'impôt c'est un pilier de ce que
nous appelons chez nous la République de
la chose publique ça c'est c'est
consubstantiel au fait que l'on
participe à la chose publique que l'on
puisse pour participer à chose publique
contribuer à la solidarité nationale
selon ce qu'on appelle ces facultés
contributives donc il faut rétablir ça
et puis pour pour les fraudeurs il y a
toute une série de de dispositions alors
j'en citerai juste quelques-unes il
faudrait améliorer l'échange
d'informations entre les États et
là-dessus il y a une directive épargne
qui a été adoptée au Parlement européen
également militant en faveur de
l'échange automatique d'informations il
faut une définition plus précise des
paradis fiscaux parce que la définition
actuelle c'est simplement de considérer
que quand des états passent 12 écoss 12
accords d'échanges d'information avec
d'autres États qui eux-mêmes peuvent
parfois être des paradis fiscaux il y a
ils sont plus sur la liste la liste
noire des paradis fiscaux or ça reste
des paradis fiscaux donc il faut changer
les critères de définition des paradis
fiscaux et puis
la principale source d'évasion fiscale
en Europe c'est sans doute
l'optimisation des des sociétés qui
jouent sur différentiel d'impôts sur les
sociétés et ici aussi au Parlement
européen nous avons voté un rapport qui
lui rapporte de Madame Thyssen qui
propose une assiette commune et
consolidée de l'impôt sur les sociétés
avec un schéma d'harmonisation des taux
sur 5 ans donc tout ça est entre les
mains du Conseil européen
malheureusement en Europe aujourd'hui
les questions fiscales se décident à
l'unanimité au conseil nous avons
problématique
sur la directive épargne l’autriche et
Luxembourg s'oppose à l'application et
ça s'applique pas alors que si on avait
un autre cadre institutionnel ou la
démocratie prévalée c'est-à-dire les
choix du Parlement pourrait être discuté
au Conseil et bien on aurait une
véritable lutte contre l'évasion fiscale
on l'a dit que c'est un problème
européen direction maintenant la Grèce
avec Germain Andrieu vous allez voir
qu'il allait être l'état de rencontre
d'une commerçante et là-bas on fait tout
aussi pour pas payer pas payer d'impôts
on a même caché la caisse à facture
regardez vous réagissez juste après
au cœur du placard le quartier
touristique d'Athènes dans certaines
rues plus d'une boutique sur 3000 la clé
sous la porte
ici la fraude fiscale n'est pas un choix
pour tous ces petits commerçants c'est
plutôt une question de survie
c'est simple on négocie avec le client
et bien sûr ça dépend du client les
grandes chaînes de vêtements font des
factures car elles n'ont pas le choix
mais pour nous petit commerce est plus
simple on est moins contrôlé et alors
vous vous le faites
mais bien sûr on a pas le choix en tant
que petite entreprise j'ai plus de 5000
euros de taxes alors que ma société et
ben c'est moi toute seule
et du coup les factures n'existent plus
vous voyez elle est cachée en bas à ma
caisse mais elle est fermée depuis deux
mois
il faut dire qu'en moins d'un an la TVA
est passé de 19 à 23%
voilà la dame cache carrément sa caisse
ça se passe en Grèce alors comment on
fait pour lutter contre l'économie
parallèle l'Europe peut pas renflouer
les caisses de la Grèce d'un côté et pas
demander à la Grèce de collecter ces
impôts votre réaction absolument si on
est paumé si on a un système de
trésorerie qui fonctionne dans des États
membres c'est eux qui payent pour les
autres ou ça fonctionne pas ça peut pas
être comme ça en Allemagne
ça marche très bien parce que la
trésorerie contrôle tout on est et
contrôle les commerçants mais on
contrôle aussi les contribuables mais
notre problème c'est que quand il y a
encore avec entre les commerçants et
ceux qui achètent ont fait moitié-moitié
comme ça c'est une situation gagnant
elle est en a rien c'est pour ça qu'il
faut tout un panoplie de mesure c'est
pas unilatéral mais il faut avant tout
un système crédible un système moderne
il faut l'informatisation de la
trésorerie sinon on arrive à rien et on
voit que la trésorerie grecque n'a même
pas des ordinateurs alors comment
peut-on faire l'Europe et un système de
trésorerie s'il y a pas ça les CD
disponibles grâce à la France en Grèce
avec les contribuables qui ont leur
argent en Suisse mais qu'est-ce que la
Grèce en a fait après deux ans et demi 3
ans rien je vous en plus sévère oui
l'Allemagne a vraiment acheté des CD on
a on les a on a poursuivi chaque cas et
c'est ce qu'il faut faire il faut il
faut vraiment que la justice la police
financière et la trésorerie qu'il
travaille ensemble pour vraiment pour
vraiment travailler et lutter contre la
fraude fiscale c'est pas simplement la
fraude à la TVA ou si c'est polémique du
billet de 500 euros il y a un chiffre
c'est un tiers des euros en circulation
en Europe et vous en avez vu des billets
de 500 euros moi j'en ai jamais vu les
policiers disent que c'est 500 euros
servent beaucoup au trafiquants et aux
fraudeur fiscaux pourquoi on les
supprime pas ces 500 euros la Banque
centrale européenne qui ne veut pas
il y a des gens qui proposent carrément
de liquide moi j'ai déjà débattu avec
des des des des
universitaires qui proposait ça bon
les mallettes qui partent de Genève
c'est beaucoup ça oui cela dit ça règle
pas le problème
comme je vous le dis les les les les les
les les principales le principal vecteur
de de lévitement et de l'optimisation
fiscale c'est c'est des transferts tout
à fait légaux
dans le dans le cadre des prix de
transfert par exemple quand les
entreprises font de l'optimisation
fiscale et que elle s'arrange pour payer
l'impôt sur les sociétés dans dans le
pays où le taux d'imposition et le moins
élevé de la même façon il y a des
produits d'épargne qui sont souscrits
tout à fait légalement dans dans des
pays où la fiscalité particulièrement
avantageuse ou les autorités sont peu
regardant donc là c'est une histoire de
de d'échange d'information une
coopération supprimer les 500 euros
seulement je suis pour si on s'attaque
pas aux transaction en espèces on ne va
jamais aboutir aux problèmes c'est pour
ça que moi je suis pour et la directive
sur le blanchiment d'argent tout est là
pour lutter contre contre les
transactions en espèces il faut juste
réduire les seuil alors l'évasion
fiscale également donc c'est c'est on
peut mettre dans un dans un paquet corn
flakes
500000 euros c'est risqué physiquement
de Genève jusque Paris on peut aussi
avoir l'invitation de certains
conseillers qui vous disent ok vous
allez fermer votre compte en Suisse
welcome une Singapour ville communiste
Singapour on va finalement jamais les
récupérer cet argent qui manque tant à
l'Europe 6 milliards qui manque à
l'Europe oui mais on peut très bien
lutter contre les paradis fiscaux en
augmentant la coopération internationale
et là il faut plus te crédibilité aussi
au sein de l'Europe ce serait déjà très
contente si on pouvait s'attaquer au
paradis fiscaux en Europe donc au sein
de l'Union et aussi
dans certains pays voisins on a depuis
2016 le Conseil a bloqué l'accord sur le
la fraude fiscale avec le Liechtenstein
et là allez-y c'est encore une fois le
Luxembourg et l'Autriche
comment on fait pour retrouver
cet argent qui manque qui manque à
l'Europe
à Singapour je vous ai tout à l'heure
un peu longuement la boîte à outils dont
on dispose sur les paradis fiscaux il
faut définir très clairement ce qu'est
un paradis fiscal la loi américaine qui
permet la communication des comptes
office des différents pays pour la
Suisse oui c'est un exemple à suivre et
puis chaque État aujourd'hui prend ses
responsabilités et il faut souligner
qu'en France aujourd'hui il vient
d'avoir de nouvelles dispositions avec
la création d'un procureur de la
République financier disposant de de
tous les moyens possibles
d'investigation donc les choses avancent
pays par pays et puis malheureusement
à l'échelle européenne ça bloque au
Conseil parce que malheureusement parce
que l'unanimité fait qu'il toujours un
pays qui dit non vous allez suivre vous
allez suivre le sujet de près absolument
c'est moi qui leur apporteur depuis et
que ça bouge pas je dois dire que si on
voit que la vérité très concrète sur la
lutte contre la fraude fiscale si je
vois le peu que nous on a fait même
depuis 2004 le Conseil à bloqué la
directive sur renforce sur le
renforcement de la coopération
administrative s'il n'y a pas d'échange
d'information s'il y a pas cet échange
ce sera le mot de la fin échange
d'information merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation donc
c'est la fin de la semaine prochaine
vous retrouvez Nora m'a dit d'ici là
bonne suite des programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires